-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
five-word resolutions
from you guys.
And thank you for
sending them in to us,
'cause it's fun
to play with you guys.
This first one is
from @DanaHartley9.
Her resolution is to
"stop calling my husband 'bro.'"
Oh, okay, yeah.
That's a...
-"Hey, bro."
-"Can you pick up
the kids from school, bro?"
This one's from @Boggle1388.
His resolution is
"join the gym, never go."
There, that's his
five-word resolution.
We've all done that.
This one is from @JennyFromat.
Her resolution is
"less upsetty, more spaghetti."
Hey!
-Yeah!
Me likey.
-That's a fantastic one.
@JennyFromat -- "Less upsetty
and more spaghetti."
-Yeah.
-That should be a T-shirt or
a bumper sticker or something.
This one's from @Daveed23.
His resolution is "stop
stepping on dumb-ass Legos."
Oh.
This one's from @CuckooBear.
His resolution is
"read more, menus don't count."
There you go.
The Cheesecake Factory --
that's kind of a book.
This last one is from @Reedy.
Her resolution is
"stop procrastinating,
will start tomorrow."
There you go.
There are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Check out more of our favorites.
Go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.